most of our company if you're Hispanic  politically you may disagree with me  okay but the way we have created our  values and principles in PHP is that you  and I can have disagreements but we can  respect each other have a conversation  together no matter of fact I welcome it  we like it we like a good discourse we  like a good debate so now having said  that  does that also get some people to say I  don't like the way this guy said this  this that yeah I don't want to do  business with them sure I probably lost  some business as well  but has it also flipped and brought some  more True Believers that we know for a  fact that we're on the same page  absolutely and have some people been  able to consume the content then say  even though I disagreed with this guy I  like the approach he takes I'd like to  go into business with them yes but to  say there is no risk I'd be naive saying  that 100 there's a risk